[Music]
welcome to Just Cause 4 and the return
of Rico Rodriguez rogue agent on a
mission that will challenge everything
in everyone he knows Rico has arrived in
the fictional South American country of
solis the largest and most breathtaking
world we've ever created every journey
into soleus will uncover history secrets
and danger never before has a Just Cause
game offered greater variety rich in all
forms of life
at first glance Solis is a beautiful
location but scratch the surface and you
will uncover oppression fear and
violence all enforced by Gabriela the
leader of the private militia
organization the black hand
Just Cause 4 takes destruction and
physics simulation to a whole new level
with the introduction of extreme weather
experience towering tornadoes that can
tear trees from the ground and level
bridges to sticks
awesome forked lightning unpredictable
and deadly sandstorms Rory blizzards
witness the spectacular destruction they
offer both the challenge to Rico as well
as creating fun opportunities for
creative sandbox gameplay
have been totally over new editions that
offer extra gameplay opportunities
bulldozers car transporters cranes and
even wrecking balls are all fun in our
world we have new handling on bikes and
cars as well as exotic vehicles like jet
skis micro Jets
Rico's grapple is now fully customizable
and has been overhauled to make it more
intuitive for newcomers while offering
greater depth for a more experienced
player the grapple now has more tethers
than ever before
and the ability to deploy booster
rockets with all-new airlifters making
the grapple incredibly powerful and
creative tool meanwhile a new story
glues together our free form go anywhere
do anything gameplay that just cause is
so famous for and the stakes for Rico
have never been high
combat and Just Cause 4 is better than
this enemies now present a far more
intelligent threat to read
each archetype comes with unique
abilities AI designed to keep the player
although
Solis is a deeply advanced systemic
world everything you've seen from the
incredible physical eyes destruction to
unparalleled draw distance is powered by
the brand-new best-in-class open world
apex engine
my hand
welcome to Just Cause pool
[Music]